hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with every compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control m a.l2-3.7.1
about that did you for the description
all right we're going to perform
maintenance on organizational systems
why they even have a control about this
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform
[Music]
into your company's on-call compliance
hero just bolt on that cape and let's go
baby let's talk about it all right
blinding Flash the obvious here watch
out yes you are required to perform
proper maintenance on your systems
I feel silly even saying it but that's
what they made Facebook memes for and
they had to make this dummy proof so
they made an entire control just for
this my friends if you're not aware
another major massive black hole of
Cyber attack vectors comes from software
that is just not properly updated okay
so very seriously here I know I make a
lot of jokes if you don't believe me
just go Google solarwinds attack and
that one was only an update that was
three months behind Okay keeping your
systems up to date is not something you
should be doing manually you should be
doing it in an automated fashion and
ultimately at the end of the day it's
all about just making sure that your
systems are properly patched and up to
date especially when it comes to
critical security patches so let's see
what the assessors are looking for on
this one fortunately they're not looking
for much uh determine if system
maintenance is performed right so
basically an assessor is going to look
at your system probably over your
shoulder uh and they're going to check
to see whether or not the maintenance is
actually done lots and lots and lots of
ways to do that you can do it through a
patch management system you can do it
through Windows SCCM you can do it
through a million different things and
of course it depends on how your system
is set up but again insert your answer
here but ultimately it's going to say x
y z uh is where you're going to look for
the evidence that things are all up to
date now uh I will tell you this at
on-call we work with defense contractors
just like you who have had this D fars
nist itar and CMC compliance stuff
dropped in their laps like a seagull on
a sunny day or like a Windows update
patch on a Tuesday night that only takes
three hours to reboot from yes and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what we're all about here baby all right
that's what we do here at on-call
compliance and you can come along with
us and be an on-call compliance hero too
how do you do it check out cmmc
compliance secrets.com or check out the
Bible below for links to get help right
now and if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance starts
roll it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
hit us in the comments below to let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance and I'll see you on the
next one
[Music]
anyway